SESSION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA OUR QUE
HAN BENNETT BERMAN BIGELOW
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BRIAN
BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY
DALY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY BLACKIE LOUIS LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN QUINN
O'DONNELL. PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS CORK CORK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE
CHANGE BALLOT THERE IS V.
APPROVED VIA VOEPEL WALDRON
WARD WEBER WICKS. WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE DAYS
PRAYER TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY FAMILY MEMBERS MATH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH. LET US
PRAY MAKE IS ALWAYS CONSCIOUS
OF OUR PURPOSE AND OUR
USEFULNESS IN THIS WORLD. HELP
US TO SEE AND USE NEW
OPPORTUNITIES TO MAKE US ALL
MORE TRULY HUMAN IN THIS PERIOD
OF HISTORY. MAY WE MAKE IT.
WHAT IS STILL VOID. AN
UNINHABITABLE A PLACE FIT. FOR
ALL OF GOD'S CHILDREN TO LIVE
IN. AND WHAT IS MEANINGLESS AND
IN HUMANE. A FEW AND HAVE
MEANING. HELP US TO MAKE A NEW
WORLD OF SERVICE AND PEACE IN
JESUS NAME AMEN. WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT IS HE
LEADS US NOTHING. READY BEGIN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
FOR WHICH IT STANDS ONE NATION.
IT IS A LITTLE YEAH R. THANK
YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED. MOVING
TO THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY GERMAN
SACRAMENTO TUESDAY BEFORE. IT'S
A MESS WALDRONSECONDS FOR THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES
FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL AND
FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA. MEMBERS
WE HAVE A SPECIAL ANNOUNCEMENT
TODAY THIS PAST FRIDAY WAS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHATEVER'S
BIRTHDAY SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WISHING HER HAPPY BELATED
BIRTHDAY.
THIS RACE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR MOTIONS. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN NAY
TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
DOLLING MARTUCCI AND WARD THAT
GUESTS AT THE DESK AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR
TODAY WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE. TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHORE TO SPEAK ON IN THE GERMAN
AND MEMORY TODAY WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE ON EIGHTEEN
A J. R. ONE PAUL WROTE TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. CLERK WILL NOTE.
PLEASE READ THE FOLLOWING ITEMS
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ITEM
FORTY FIVE E. C. R. FOUR NINETY
SEVEN. MY LOTUS ITEM FIFTY
THREE SB FIVE FORTY FOUR LAYERS
THE CLERK WILL KNOW. PURSUANT
TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
COMMITTEE. SB TWO TWENTY SEVEN
JONES FROM THE WATER PERSON ONE
MUST BE READY TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. AND
SB FIVE THIRTY THREE STERN FOR
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SHALL BE
ORDER. MEMBERS WE HAVE QUITE A
FEW GET WITH US ON THE FLOOR.
SO WE WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THEM. ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY HAS
HER DAUGHTER AT HER DEATH SO
PLEASE GIVE A WARM WELCOME TO
MR ALI'S DAUGHTER ROSLYN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD HAS HIS
CHILDREN ON THE FLOOR TODAY AND
HIS HAS BEEN. GIVE THEM A WARM
WELCOME HE SAYS IT IS IN THE
GALLERY. AND LASTLY A MISTER
MERRICK SAID SHE HAS. HIS
DAUGHTER SOPHIA AND HIS STAFF
WELCOME.
MEMBERS OF THE MOVIE
TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING. READ SENATE
BILL FIVE OH THREE WITH A
MINUTE SIX THIRTY NINE WITH THE
MINUTES EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS
FOR THREE WITH A MEMBERS FOR
SEVENTY EIGHT WITH A MEMBERS
FIVE FIFTY TWO THE MEMBER SEVEN
TWELVE THE MEDICINE WITH THE
MINUTES. SENATE BILL FOUR
FOURTEEN CYNICAL TO TWENTY TO
THE MOMENT SIX CITY FOR THE
MEMBERS TWENTY EIGHT WITH A
MEMBERS TONIGHT I'M WITH HIM
IT'S NOT AND I'M OF THE MINUTES
AND SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY
ONE OF THE MINUTES. THANK YOU
ALL BILLS WILL BE DEEMED READ
ALL MENTAL BE DEEMED ADOPTED.
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING. MEMBERS WE WILL PASS
AND RETAIN ON ITEM FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN TO NINETEEN
MOVING THE FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY EIGHT OR THIRTY NINE
HARPER REED. PULSE WAS SOLUTION
THIRTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
EQUITY IMPACT ANALYSIS OF
LEGISLATION EVER GIPSON YOU MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO. ZACKS HR
THIRTY NINE THIS RESOLUTION
ENCOURAGE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY TO EXPLORE METHODS TO
FORMALLY INTEGRATE EQUITY IN
THE IMPACT OF EQUITIES IN
EXISTING COMMITTEES AND FLOOR
ANALYSIS FOR LEGISLATION AND
EQUITY IMPACT ANALYSIS WOULD BE
THE ANALYTICS LIENS THAT
COMMITTEES COULD ADOPT TO
ENSURE THAT LEGISLATION DOES
NOT NEGATIVELY. COMPROMISE THE
LEVEL OF OPPORTUNITY SERVICE OR
A SUPPORT THAT LOW INCOME AND
MODERATE INCOME COMMUNITIES
RECEIVE HARDWORKING COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS KNOW BEST IT IS THE
INTENT OF HR THIRTY NINE TO
ENCOURAGE NOT TO MANDATE. THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE EQUITY LENS
FOR LEGISLATION ANALYSIS MY
HOPE IS THAT WHEN WE TAKE A
CLOSER LOOK AT LEGISLATION
THROUGH THE EQUITY LANDS. WE
INSURE THAT OUR CONSTITUENTS
HAVE EQUAL ACCESS TO SERVICES
SUCH AS QUALITY CARE FINANCIAL
AID FOR HIGHER EDUCATION AND
HOME OWNERSHIP. STRUCTURAL
RACISM AFFECTS THE MOST
VULNERABLE PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY COBIT NINETEEN
EXPLORES DISPARITIES IN HEALTH
EDUCATION. ECONOMIC OUTCOMES
FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES
EXPRESSLY FAMILIES OF COLOR NOW
MORE THAN EVER EQUITY MATTERS
IN CALIFORNIA PUTTING EQUITY AT
THE FOREFRONT OF OUR WORK WILL
HELP IDENTIFY GAPS IN OUR
DECISION MAKING PROCESS AS WELL
AS INTRODUCE- OR BOTH ONE PIECE
OF LEGISLATION WITHOUT IT
EQUITY FOCUS LANDS WE CANNOT DO
THE PEOPLE'S BUSINESS WE HEARD
COMMUNITIES THAT WE'RE
ABSOLUTELY TRYING TO HELP I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WOULD I VOTE.
ON HR THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU
MISTER GIPSON- SOME OF THE
RIVER CA YOU RECOGNIZE YOUR
DESK. THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM CARSON FOR
BRINGING THIS FORTH. I THINK IN
THIS CHAMBER WE OFTEN TALK AND
MY NINE YEARS HERE WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT EQUITY AND HOW
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR LONG COMMUNITIES HAVE
BEEN LEFT BEHIND. AND I WANT TO
THINK THAT THAT'S NOT
INTENTIONAL I DON'T THINK IT'S
EVER BEEN ARE INTENDED TO HAVE
TO CALIFORNIANS I THINK WE ARE
COMMITTED TO THE IDEA ONE
CALIFORNIA THAT'S JUST AN EQUAL
FOR ALL. BUT THE REALITY IS
THAT IF WE'RE NOT INTENTIONAL
WITH OUR POLICY WERE NOT ASKING
YOURSELF THESE QUESTIONS OF
EQUITY WE'RE GOING TO KEEP
LEAVING BEHIND COMMUNITIES LIKE
OURS AND WE'VE SEEN IT
MAGNIFIED DURING THIS COLD ED
PANDEMIC. THAT WE'VE ALL BEEN
STRUGGLING WITH AN ACID ALL
OVER COMMUNITIES HARD BUT
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN
HIT A LITTLE BIT HARDER AND
REALLY FAST AND AT THE END
WOMEN AT THE END OF THE LINE I
LIVE IN ONE OF THOSE DISTRICTS.
WHERE WE ARE BEING HIT HARD-
AND RIGHT NOW IS A QUICKLY
RACES- CASES ARE CLIMBING AGAIN
WE'VE SEEN THAT IN MY COMMUNITY
AGAIN AND THOSE BENEFITS TOOK
AWHILE TO GET THERE ALONG THE
WAY AND SO I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR REMINDING US THAT. WE HAVE
THE POTENTIAL TO BE EQUITABLE
IT'S UP AFTER SOMETIME QUESTION
ON A REGULAR BASIS AND I DO AS
A VERY PRAGMATIC MEASURE PUT
PUTTING FORWARD AND SO. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER. SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
MISTER GIBSON YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES- FROM BILL
GUARDS FOR HER- GENEROUS
COMMENTS AGAIN MEMBERS I WANT
TO PIGGY BACK ON WHAT SOMETHING
THAT OUR MEMBER JESS
ARTICULATES ALL OF US WE CANNOT
HAVE TO CALIFORNIA'S ALMOND SO
THIS IS A RESOLUTION BEFORE US
TODAY I'M SEEK TO MAKING SURE
THAT WE- INTRODUCED LEGISLATION
THAT WE DO IT FROM EQUITABLE.
LIENS AND TO MAKING SURE THAT
WE DON'T DO ANYTHING TO HURT
THE VERY PEOPLE THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO HELP SO AGAIN THIS IS
NOT A MANDATE WE EMPOWER OUR
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS TO DO THE
WORK- THERE ARE ALREADY
CONSULTANTS WHO ARE DOING THIS
WORK RIGHT NOW AND I JUST ASK
HIS BODY TO MOVE FORWARD BY
MAKING SURE THAT WE LOOK AT
LEGISLATION FROM EQUITABLE
LIMBS I RESPECTFULLY ASK WOULD
I VOTE ON HR THIRTY NINE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SOME OF YOUR THE
FIRST ROLE OPEN FOR COLLECTORS.
THANK YOU FOR GOAL OVER THE
ROLE. HI THIS FOR COOPER'S
NUMBER ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO FOCUS THE
FOR CO AUTHORS ON HR THIRTY
NINE FILE ITEM. TWENTY BURKE
WILL CLOSE ROLE COUNTY VOTERS
THERE ARE FIFTY FIVE CO AUTHORS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL TAKE A
VOICEMAIL ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL
THOSE OPPOSED SAY NAY THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MOVING
ON TO A PASS AND RETAINING ON
FILE ITEMS NUMBER TWENTY ONE
THROUGH THIRTY SIX THIS IS FILE
ITEM NAME NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS. LOCAL
READ. SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY
TWO WITH A MINUTES BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PARA QUE HAN SOME OF OUR
CAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY ARE
QUIET RISE REQUESTED AMENDMENTS
TO SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY TO
BE ADOPTED WHICH NEARLY ADDED
URGENCY BECAUSE OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THESE AMEDMENTS
ADOPTED IN THE BILL GO OUT TO
PRINT A BACK ON FILE. THANK YOU
SOME OF OUR CAN. SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE THEIR
QUESTIONS IF THERE'S NO
OBJECTION WE CAN TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. ALL
THOSE OPPOSED SAY NO. AYE AYES
HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS ARE OUT
TO PRINT AND BACK ON FILE. AND
THEN THE THIRD OPTION. HILL
THOUSAND PRINT BACK ON FILE
THANK YOU. WE WILL PASS AND
RETAIN ON ON FILE ITEMS THIRTY
EIGHT TO FORTY FOUR. NOW MOVES
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR DOES
ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ART SCENE HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND EXACT
COLOR SENATE BILL THREE SIXTY
BY THE SOONER WE'LL AN ACCOLADE
INTO ESCROW AGENT RATING
SERVICES ORACLE OPEN ROLE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ALL
MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE THE FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED. FOR ANY ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION WILL NOW MOVE TO ANY
PREVIOUSLY NO. AND ALSO THE
GERMANS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS ORTEGA
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS ARE BIGGER
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR. A.
DR CHOI YOUR RECOGNIZING YOUR
DESK FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN.
MAY NOT AREN'T WITH THE KERR
POOL PASSED AWAY JUNE TWENTY
SECOND AT THE SAINT JOSEPH
HOSPITAL IN THE CITY OF ORANGE
AT THE AGE OF ALL NINETY FIVE.
BORN JULY TWENTY FIFTH OF
NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE IN
CAMBRIDGE MASS ASSUME
MASSACHUSETTS TO OUR FAMILY
PROUD OF WHAT IS THE HERITAGE
OF GOING BACK TO THE FOUNDING
OF A MASSACHUSETTS AND THE
SERVICE OF FROM THE REVOLUTION
TO THE CIVIL WAR AND THE WAR
THE WAR ON. ONE WOULD WANT TO
ARRIVE DAY DO DO YOU CALLED AND
THE MISTER WHITAKER VOLUNTEERED
AS A SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD. ASKING
HIS SOME PARENTS OUGHT TO SIGN
THE PERMISSION FORM BEING ON
THE H. MISTER WHITAKER.
MILITARY WITH THE KERN SOME
MILITARY THAT. DECORATIONS
INCLUDE THE DISTINGUISHED UNIT
CITATION THE BRONZE STAR PURPLE
HEART. WE'LL GO TO VICTORY MATT
ALL COMBAT INFANTRY BADGE AND
THE FRENCH LEGION OF HONOR.
AFTER THE WAR MISTER WHITAKER
ATTENDED THE STANFORD
UNIVERSITY AND THE GRADUATED
DAHLE IN. NINETEEN FIFTY THREE
WITH THE HONORS HE THEN THE
BEGAN A SIXTY YEAR OLD FOR THE
CAREER SO LIFE HEALTH AND OUR
DISABILITY INSURANCE BROKER
WITH THE ACTIVE OF CLIENTS OFF
UNTIL THE DAY HE PASSED AWAY.
MISTER WHITAKER SERVED IN MANY
PLACES ALL OF OUR COMMUNITY
LEADERSHIP HIS SERVE THE
SEVENTEEN YEARS SAW ON THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY CENTRAL
COMMITTEE WITH THE THREE
DIFFERENT TERMS SO CHAIRMAN. HE
WAS ALSO A SUNDAY SCHOOL
TEACHER AT THE SAINT MARKS A
SPEAKER SB CORPORAL CHURCH IN
GLENDALE. JERRY FARBER HAS
SAUCE ON THE SIDE INDIAN GUYS
STRIDE PRESIDENT OF THE
FELLOWSHIP CLUB AHEAD DOES IT
MARKS A AND THE PRESIDENT OF
THE PRESIDENT SOUGHT ADVISORY
COUNCIL IN GLENDALE. HE ALSO
DEDICATED THE ALMOST A TWENTY
YEAR OR SO CLOSE TO BREAKING TO
A SCHOOL CHILDREN IN THE FIFTY
FIFTH EIGHTH AND ELEVENTH-
GRADERS SAW IN ALL ALL ALL OVER
ORANGE COUNTY AND- THE INDIAN
M. NOW. INLAND EMPIRE ABOUT THE
HIS TO WORK EXPERIENCES HE-
TRANSLATED THE NOT THAT I THINK
OF A SERVICE AND THE DOING HARD
THINGS SO DELIGHTFUL LESSONS SO
FOR STUDENTS. MISTER WHITAKER
IS TO SURVIVE THE BY HIS- A TWO
SONS OF FRED AND THE CHARLES
THE ORDER UP TOTALING. MIGNON
AND ALL HIS OF THREE OF THE OLD
SOFTWARE AND CHILDREN- JANE AND
THE **** PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
JOINING THE MEMORY OF A FRIEND
MAY NOT THE WITH THE CAR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU DR
CHOI PLEASE BRING THE NAME TO
THE DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUEST TO ADJOURN
THE MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE WILL
BE MEETING IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER THIRTY MINUTES AFTER
ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION. THE
SERGEANTS SCHEDULE SEVEN SEVEN
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
JULY SIXTH CHECK IN SESSION
WEDNESDAY JULY SEVENTH IS
CHECKING SESSION THURSDAY JULY
EIGHTH MORE SESSION NINE AM ALL
OTHER ITEMS FROM WILL BE PASSED
RETAIN ALL NATIONS SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS ALL MOVE A
TAKE A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER CALDERON MOTIONS JUST
EIGHTY SECONDS OF THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
JULY EIGHTH AT. NINE AM QUORUM
CALLS LIFTED.